Wow um I kind of wish I'd written notes
now I was sitting watching everybody
come up and accept their award so I
started scribbling on a place card um I
don't actually know whose place card it
is someone called Natasha McNamara I
mean she's not even on my table but I
started scribbling on her place card and
I'd like to start by oh I have to raise
it that doesn't happen often I'd like to
start by congratulating oh my god I
didn't even leave I am so sorry Brooklyn
I'm so sorry
they told me to be funny but that was
completely off the cuff that was great
um I'd like to start by congratulating
all the women here tonight and also
Harry Potter that that have won awards
you know I love to celebrate women um go
power and and you know Joe thank you so
much it's great when women support women
and I think what Marlene Myleene Klass
said was spot-on we need more women out
there supporting women so
congratulations to everybody thank you
so much Joe and the glamour team Thank
You Christopher for such kind words
Thank You Brooklyn my date tonight who
is the most handsome man in the room
tonight I'm sure that's really pissed
off David Gandy but Thank You Brooklyn
for bringing mommy and avoiding your
homework tonight thank you to my mom and
dad for always being there my sister my
team my husband who who does everything
for me he supports me he encourages me
to follow my dreams and fulfill my
passion so thank you David even though
you're not here the other man in my life
Simon Fuller I couldn't do anything that
I do without his support so thank you
and wow what an amazing ten years I was
thinking that I have been so lucky and
so blessed to have two careers and I
really do feel truly truly blessed
here's the next ten years and I was just
thinking about that thinking
I will be nearly 50 in ten years I will
be nearly 50 but thank you so much for
your support
Joe my family and here's to the next 10
years thank you and I got a gold one Wow
thank you
you